good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy
wednesday hump day here at the morning
toast i'm so excited to be joined
in you know i miss jackie but if there
had to be anyone sitting in her seat
i'm so glad it is my good friend radio
host taylor strecker hello taylor how
are you doing today
hey girl hey i'm doing fabulously hey
girl hey
hey girl i'm so excited you're here
thank you so much for being here
the toasters love you i love you i know
we're gonna have a killer show you were
actually with me
on the show like two wednesdays ago
maybe three yes and we did
advice for the deer toaster segment and
people your reviews were so rave
really yeah because we actually had one
um
about someone's brother who might be gay
and you actually just offered really
good insight as
a late in life lesbian yes so i was
really grateful for you for being here
and i'm so excited that you're here
again thank you i will i haven't been to
the new studio
what do you think thing for and the
location location location
location you look amazing like a gilded
goddess like an oscar
you are my oscar thank you for being
here such an honor to be nominated
the academy sent me we have been hanging
out so much recently and that brings me
so much joy
me too i love your work and pleasure i
love you so much this weekend was so
fabulous so fabulous taylor and her
girlfriend taylor
were both up in pennsylvania with me ben
bryant it was literally the best weekend
and i'm so glad i get to see you again i
know wait you're really good at sharing
friends i just want to say that because
that's like a thing
that i'm actually truly so funny that
you say that because like i actually
think i'm terrible at that
but when you know that two of your
friends like are meant to be friends
yes and it enhances the whole group vibe
do you know what i mean
right i know but like i was saying
claudia before we started i had such
deep anxiety and like i used to be the
kind of person if i got anxious i would
hate everybody that
made me anxious even though i make me
anxious even though i'm the problem
but i was like fully aware that it was
me
but i had like i was living in the land
of bathos driving home like
it was like highs and lows like i was
like living for the weekend and then i
would be like why did i
say that to somebody we drank a lot like
when we like didn't need to like at
every single point in the day it was
like a mini bender in the country
i mean i was next level sunday next you
were next level sunday like
i was sober i drove taylor to the
grocery store because we needed things
for nachos obviously
i was just like the sober person in the
car like everyone was annoying me
because like you guys were having the
best time and i was like can we just get
the things and get the [ __ ] out of the
grocery store
but taylor was like doing cartwheels
you're really scary
you're stalling at a grocery store no
and when i'm sober stalin like it's the
worst
no 100 but like i have no regrets
because it was such a good weekend it
was so great i'm so
so thrilled that you're here we have a
crazy show today do you see all these
cards you guys
thick we got a lot of stories it's
wednesday we have deer toasters which is
our advice segment
um and i'm really excited to do all that
there's not a ton of you know pop
culture news
but yesterday was like a historic crazy
day i think a lot of people have been
waiting
for the derek chauvin verdict and
yesterday we got it guilty on all three
counts yes
and it was crazy like i was in a meeting
and i was refreshing twitter like the
whole time and it was just you i really
did not know
of course the man is guilty but you just
never know with these things like what
my god
is going to decide and i just think a
lot of people felt like a huge
sigh of relief even though this was like
a trial that should have never happened
like
george floyd should be alive totally so
i was watching it right before i was
recording my last hour of
my radio show the taylor striker show
and i
was like such a ball of emotion and
it was so nerve-wracking watching the
virta come in because i was like if this
goes left if this goes wrong
like i'm i don't even want to be a part
of this country like how do we go move
on from that there's literally a video
of it happening
and that's not enough to convict someone
it's but like
the fact that i was nervous about that
says a lot a lot and
it's like as much as this is like a
victory it's a small victory because
first of all george floyd shouldn't even
be dead and second of all it's like
this is coming you know on the on the
heels of
you know four more black people dying at
the hands of police exactly
yesterday a 14 year old mikaya bryant
like dante wright it's just
it seems like this never-ending thing
and i can only imagine how
harring it is to be you know a black
person experiencing this in america
but small very small win
i saw you know it's not justice it's
accountability right and that's the
thing and i think that
a lot of people's initial reaction was
like justice has been served right and
then i think you start to go through the
range of emotions and so my co-host and
i were like we can't even really speak
to this right now because we like
literally are in shock recovery and it's
like we are feeling relieved we're also
feeling sad like it was just such a
it's a lot to unpack a ton to unpack so
there's still
more work to be done but i think a lot
of people
feel in a small way this is you know a
full circle it's been almost a year
since
you know we all saw that video so to
close that particular chapter
feels like it's as good as it's going to
get
proud of the jury for sure and
definitely
i think that it is it's the beginning
it's the beginning yeah for sure um so
that is good news good news good news
good news but uh we're gonna move on
with the show and deliver the past five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast
two days in a row i know um okay so
today's episode is brought to you by
bruce do you have a brush toothbrush
no oh we have to get you one it's
literally the official toothbrush of the
morning toast
it is the best electric toothbrush a lot
of electric toothbrushes can cost over
200
which is like the price of a handbag so
that's insane yeah but bruce is very
reasonably priced and in my opinion it
is the best
electric toothbrush on the market i know
so many of you guys have gotten it yet
but if you haven't yet we have a code
the bruce has six unique modes to
customize your brushing experience the
battery life lasts four weeks so if
you're traveling you don't have to bring
your charger with you unless you're
traveling for more than a month in which
case
i'm jealous um the charging stand is
magnetic it's very elegant very tesla
like it doesn't take up a lot of clutter
on your um cabinets and it comes with a
compact travel case too
they also offer a subscription program
so you never forget to change your brush
head again
bruce will ship you new replacement
heads every six months so you're never
stuck using a worn down brush head
the electric toothbrush has a modern
aesthetically pleasing design
and it comes in trend driven seasonal
colors and it looks great on your
bathroom counter it's also a great gift
um if you want to get 15 off your bruce
toothbrush kit and the refill plan use
the promo code toast
brush.com that's 15 off promo code toast
at bruush.com i'm getting it
it's so good you sold me on the tesla
stand because mine's got a wire and it
drives me
nuts it has a very thin wire and the
stand is like literally this big it's
elegant
i want it okay so celebrity news not
gonna lie nothing crazy happened in the
last 24 hours yeah
but chrissy tegan didn't go on watch
robin's live and spill a little bit of
tea
i saw on kim and kanye okay according to
page six kim karda according to chrissy
teigen
via page six right kim kardashian gave
her all in the marriage to kanye west
chrissy teigen said it's a shame that
kim kardashian and kanye west's marriage
is ending
but vowed the reality star gave her all
to make it work
the supermodel who's friends with
kardashian said she'd spoken to
kim in the wake of the split quote i've
definitely been in touch with kim more
than my husband john has been in touch
with kanye
anyone knows kanye knows that anyone who
knows kanye it's that he goes off the
grid teagan added chuckling right it's
hard to ever contact kanye but kim is
doing okay i know kane
kim gave her all for everything so she's
making it abundantly clear like her and
john are on team kim
yes i mean well first of all i just want
to say that it seems like uh my
fiance is kim and i am kanye you can
never get in touch with me
which is the worst thing in the world so
but like kanye does seem very like
withdrawn
and yeah he's like it's such an
egomaniac yes
i mean even without christie saying this
i would say i would even be
team kim and by the way i do believe
that kim really tried her best
yeah how many times have she been
married trust me that'll motivate a
[ __ ] no and
it's like if you think of all the things
she's actually put up with
from kanye like him running for
president like you know in such a a
difficult climate and a lot of people
were really unhappy with him doing that
like
yeah i just think she put up with so
much and she never wavered in her
support of him and his work and his art
and their family so
i i knew this already like i do believe
like she really tried her absolute best
so he recently came out in a story maybe
like last week
and he was saying how in his next
relationship he really wants to be
an artist shady that's the shady as [ __ ]
also like the fact it's just hard for
for kanye like he has to go from
marrying kim to dating someone else when
in my opinion
kim is the most elegant fabulous
sophisticated famous stunning beautiful
smart
in the world yes and honestly for kanye
like it can really only go down
but kanye's reputation in the last few
years has kind of been squandered so
likely
kim it's all it's up for kim you know i
have you know i've had
a range of emotions about kim over the
years but i've settled on
for the most part i think she's yes epic
and fabulous and iconic
so we will not tolerate any other sort
of
verbiage here on the show which is why i
changed my opinion
um i do think that she's going to be
like beyond fine
um and it makes me sad because i do like
college dropout kanye
is my everything i know but like i have
to remember that he's not
that i mean he yelled at taylor swift
yeah that alone
that alone oh no i mean the running for
president was pretty bad and there's
been a lot in between
i know so like it it must have been
i mean it was painful for us to watch
yeah he went on those
and and he's publicly struggling with
his mental health and i think kim has
just been kind of
wanting struggling with you know wanting
to help in keeping a private matter and
then kanye
blowing it up on twitter and stuff so
kim has been through a lot they both
have
and honestly as much as it pains me i do
think that this is for the best
it is for the best i do feel like when
they first got together though it was
like
when she was bringing her out with jay-z
and beyonce i felt like
she was the underdog and now clearly
she has surpassed him 100 percent she
always talks about how the first met
gala she went to she was only invited
because she was kanye's date
and like she said literally no one would
talk to her like it was the most awkward
thing ever and now like literally
every single designer would die
literally
die to have kim there as their you know
their guest which is such a crazy full
circle thing and
one of my favorite things about kim is
like in her eat your hollywood story and
i've heard her say this a lot of times
before is that like
when kanye first started dating kim kim
was considered like a trash reality star
totally sex tape like it was really
considered low brow and kanye was this
mega artist genius genius
influence influential artist and he was
unapologetic in her love for her and he
brought her around everywhere and he
like always stood by her and she was
like it meant so much to me that like he
was never embarrassed of me like
he always brought me out he was so proud
to be my my boyfriend and like
that's that's the kim and kanye that i
love and i love that they always at the
end of the day like have this respect
for each other yeah and he
was obsessed with her obsessed and i
hope that they maintain that level of
respect
it's for no other sake than for their
kids you know well yeah public divorces
are
so messy i have a question and i'm
saying this as a social climber yeah is
kim the greatest social climber of all
time
uh yeah but you know what at some point
it's not social climbing it's networking
i like that yeah like isn't it funny how
they're literally the same thing
yes there's but one is like wow she's
such a great networker and the other is
like what a social climate
it's all about the inflection in your
voice when they're literally the same
thing i'm the latter
i am a social climbing networker i'm a
social climbing common networking
thirst monster and i feel like i'm
pretty good at it
you're phenomenal i think that's why
we're friends i love social climbing
like i feel like there's really
nothing wrong with that i think it's
fabulous i've been doing it since i was
a wee wee child
and like sorry that i just want to
advance my personal and professional
life wait
who is your first person you ever social
climbed i mean you have to think of it
like on what scale like in high school
or like i wanted to go first it sounds
like you have an answer i do have an
answer
my first social climb was kate bosworth
okay she moved to my town
as like being in the horse whisperer and
i was like i will make that girl my
friend because she's going to be a star
and i will ride her coattails
all the way to talking before she was
famous i mean she wasn't that famous she
had like just an
opening scene in the horse whisperer and
then she's
so she moved to our town like as like a
hollywood whatever
everyone was like shook it totally and
she's gorge gorgeous and then
we all hung out obviously high school
and then she did blue crush
our senior year oh so yeah was she in
your high school
so i left the high school and i was
devastated when i was like wait a famous
person's finally moving to town
but then i also wanted to be the famous
person it was a really it was a struggle
and she set me up with my first
boyfriend
wait what you don't know this wait
i literally will never shut up about the
story like my audience is like if you
say kate boss with one more [ __ ] time
we're gonna kill you we have that here
at the morning toast i use a lot of the
same stories i always talk about the
fact that the paparazzi
um had the absolute gall to show up at
dennis's bethany's ex-fiance general and
like photograph
him and her family yes and it's horrible
it's always like my point of reference
when i say like the media is so [ __ ]
up but it's like and remember that time
the paparazzi went to dennis's funeral
like and now it's like lost it's you
know yes okay sorry continue
so yeah she moved to town she
i left for all girl catholic school
which is lesbian bringing ground as far
as i'm concerned
and when i came up to my parents i was
like what did you
expect when you sent me to an all-girls
catholic school and so i was
happy to leave the public school because
i was just getting tortured by the kids
in my class
but when she moved in i was like i
wanted to hang out with her but i also
liked
i felt strong competition with her i
know and my best friend in middle school
he would like torture me with her so he
would be like guess who's coming over to
watch dawson squeak tonight and i was
like whoo he was like kate i was like
can i come he's like
no you left me went to private school
and i'm so pissed so she was like really
part of like the social fabric of your
school
yes and then we went on this appalachia
tour not tour but it was like um
habitat for humanity and we went and
build houses and we were all sleeping at
like
high schools on floors like in like
sleeping bags
and kate was at my center not on my team
but at my center
and so i was like let's smoke cigs and
become best friends and so we were like
like it was so like did you get kate
bosworth into cigarettes
i feel like the boys on the trip got us
into cigarettes we were like all split
one
all 15 of us that's like not in not in
today's climate with koben you're all
sharing a cigarette i'm not so
sick not covered safe and then i made
her my friend and she told me i had
great skin at the time i did
and then um she introduced me to her
ex-boyfriend who then became like my
first
real boyfriend wait this is the craziest
story of crazy i've known you for so
long and i didn't know this so have you
run into her
in post yes like a handful of times in
different ways and it's always a
different scenario
and does she remember you she does but
it was like i remember the very first
time because
like i i had like reoccurring dreams of
like running into her
of course so i was out in la for my
junior year of college and my
roommate slash really good friend was um
like interning at a
uh entertainment like legal office okay
so her job was to deliver scripts to
clients
so one day she knocks on the door and it
opens it's kate bosworth and she was
like oh my god i know taylor strecker
and kate was like no [ __ ] way tell
her to call me i can't believe it what a
small world blah blah blah and then of
course
never called but like whatevsky yeah and
then like maybe
three or four or five years later when i
was working get serious i was
like obsessed with like she's gonna come
in here at some point i'm gonna
interview her like
what's it gonna be like and i was at the
solo house having lunch with like my
team from the radio show and all of a
sudden my co-host kenny was like
don't look now kate boss with the skill
and i was like so
i got up and walked over and i was like
oh my god kate hello
and she was like it wasn't mean at all
but it wasn't like
oh my it's not like but she's like very
like whisper tone
fragile small woman it was very like
oh how nice to see you like we had just
seen each other
three days earlier at the pta meeting
right it was just so weirdly calm
yeah like if you and i like if we walked
out of here and then ran into each other
on the street five minutes later we
would be like
wow yeah yeah i actually met her once
and she pulled it nice to see you and
i'm like [ __ ] we've never met
but like that's obviously like what
celebrities do because like that's
me right that's why i'm saying it sounds
kind of familiar and that was the first
time i ever experienced like that's a
thing in hollywood people always just
say nice to see you and yeah nice to
meet you and i felt like such a dope for
me like nice to meet you so
i learned my lesson real [ __ ] quick
um well thank you for sharing that that
is welcome so fascinating you're welcome
next story a little royal drama an
obsessed woman gets into prince andrew's
home by pretending to be
his date of course a woman obsessed with
prince andrew i can't believe that that
person exists
like who would be obsessed with this
creepy ass pedophile
a woman obsessed with prince andrew
managed to trick her way into his
official residence
by pretending she was there for a date
wandering her she was wandering around
for at least 20 minutes while he was
home according to a report
my god this smartly dressed 44 year old
spanish woman was so convincing and
saying she had a lunch date with the
duke that security guards even paid for
her taxi when she arrived
at the royal lodge on uh on monday oh my
god she then spent at least 20 minutes
wandering around his gardens
that sounds like lovely no that sounds
um like sexual
can i wander around your gardens check
out some of your bushes
she spent at least 20 minutes wandering
around his gardens before heading inside
while he was home
she was very confident and walked around
like she owned the place the source said
she cut quite a glamorous figure and the
guards were completely taken by her
they had no idea this woman was a total
stranger to andrew and seemingly had a
fixation with him oh my god she
reportedly only gave herself away when
she started talking to a member of the
staff to try and find out where andrew
was
to the staff member's shock the woman
then claimed to be engaged to prince
andrew
and said she was there to get married
tim the source told the sun she said
that that was the reason why she had
flown over from spain a couple days
earlier
by all accounts the woman had a map of
the royal lodge and other royal
residences including buckingham palace
in her handbag
she was also found to have a key ring
that was in the shape of a cat which had
spikes on it that could be used as
self-defense of course it was a cat that
potential weapon apparently caused
the police some concern so um
you know what i just think is so funny
well not funny but it's clear that like
prince andrew just has like women
running about
his palace at all times that like the
guards you shouldn't really be able to
penetrate
a royal palace interesting word yeah
right
right so if there's like a situation
where a woman just gets in like that's
because women are just coming there all
the time
exactly
i think that under normal circumstances
i feel bad for celebs when they're like
you know started by creepers
i agree but in this case he's the number
one creep so i actually
am here for this i love her she's a
she's a heroine she is a national hero
she is she deserves a monument outside
buckingham palace she's a treasure
i literally [ __ ] hate prince andrew i
hate him so much for a multitude of
reasons up for the obvious ones but more
so because like
it's frustrating to see someone like
abuse their power so wholeheartedly
and have absolutely no consequence
consequences no
questions no punishment like he should
be in prison uh
big time and like imagine being so
cavalier and so
powerful that like you are literally the
most disgusting person ever and you sit
down for an interview like thinking you
have nothing to hide have you ever seen
that like famous bbc interview
i haven't seen it but i feel like what i
saw from the jeffrey epstein dock
it's just like like he has so much blood
on his hands it is unbelievable
and then it super triggered me with the
whole meghan markle prince harry things
that's like
so wait you guys literally go out of
your way to
cover the [ __ ] out of this guy's tracks
and you can't even correct a story and
you can't even just like protect family
like
yeah no no prince andrew was literally
like a monster
he doesn't know it but he's my
archnemesis he doesn't know but he'll
know it soon because i'm going to sneak
into that
i was going to say
his garden see how he likes it
um no he's an actual piece of [ __ ] and i
hate even reporting on him but this was
something i hope he felt unsafe in his
own home me too
brings me joy to think just merely the
idea gives me chills
um we have more stories for you guys but
the rest of the show is brought to you
by skylight frames
if you're not able to visit your mom dad
grandparents
a great gift idea is the skylight frame
it's a touch screen photo frame
that you can email photos to and they'll
appear in seconds so your mom or grandma
can see your favorite moments
so a lot of people said this is a great
gift because it's just it's great for
yourself
but also if you have a grandparent who's
older or a parent who's older who
doesn't really know how
they're not really tech savvy you set it
up for them and then from your phone you
don't even have to be in the house
you can like send them photos like
you're at the park with your kid or your
cousin
it's a really cute idea and a lot of
people always message me like what was
the code for twilight
skylight frames so listen up staying in
touch with those we love is more
important than ever and the easiest way
to do it is with skylight
a photo frame you can email photos to
anytime anywhere
it's a great way to feel close to those
that you love even when you're far away
you can tap the heart button it will let
the sender know you love the photo you
can engage with them
it's really a great gift and they have
100 satisfaction guarantee
if you don't love your skylight they'll
offer you a full refund
it is a gorgeous 10 inch touchscreen you
can swipe through photos with your
finger and even tap to thank the person
who sent the photo
it's so simple even non-tech savvy
parents can set it up and use it
the customers who have bought the
skylight frames love it
you will too a special offer you can get
10 off your first purchase of a skylight
frame
when you go to skylightframe.com the
code toast
to get ten dollars off your first
purchase of skylightframes.com
code toast skylight is s-k-y-l-i-g-h-t
frame dot com code toast uh we actually
got one for ben's parents and they like
die for it we we don't have kids yet so
all we do is put up pictures of theo
um and they die for it so it's a great
gift for a parent but it's also great
for your house like i
i've seen a million people who have
those frames and i think they're great
skylightframes.com and mother's day is
coming up yes
it is yes um okay on to more celebs
salacious news
uh hayden panettiere's ex-boyfriend is
going to jail
oh he's a bad bad boy hayden
panettiere's ex-boyfriend brian
hickerson has been sentenced to 45 days
in county jail according to multiple
reports
entertainment tonight reached out to
their attorney for comment but we
haven't heard anything
the 31 year old was sentenced following
multiple domestic violence allegations
involving
involving panettiere over the last few
years on tuesday hickerson pled
no contest to two felony counts of
injuring a spouse or girlfriend
he begins serving his sentence on may
7th in addition to the jail time he was
also sentenced to four years of formal
probation
52 domestic violence classes and 500 in
restitution
and a five-year protective order wow
this has been like the longest
right i was gonna say is this the only
boyfriend or it
has there been multiple that's how long
it feels it's been a long journey and i
feel so bad for hayden peniteer because
she has just been through a lot like she
really has and she's really kind of
like stepped out of the spotlight
because i think she's just had a lot of
things going on in her personal life
um she suffered from really bad uh
postpartum depression and then dealt
with this [ __ ] like
i just i love her she's in like so many
of my favorite most iconic like movies
that i grew up with like bring it on
to um and also raising helen like she's
just an iconic actress and i love her
and then she was great in nashville
i loved her in nashville do you love
nashville love
that show oh i didn't know that yeah i
know i feel like you
don't think i like country i i'm not
like a stan the way you are but you're i
know taylor donahue your
fiance i feel sorry is but i didn't know
that you were
she's she's lying she's we are equal
country fans okay
i taught her about chicken fried just
for the record
song such a good song but i'm like it's
like
50 50 with me with country yeah but yeah
but watching the amc
awards amc's movie theater
i kept getting up and leaving
yeah we were all watching the acm awards
until i was like this is great and then
left
she like sat outside i was it was good
you missed it you missed it but i do
like nashville i love it and i really
did
like learn to love hayden um her
character was so annoying in the
beginning
very annoying but she i feel so so
deeply bad for her i mean this is just
i can't really remember like all of the
stories around it
but no one's either because she's really
roughed her up she's so private now like
and she has been for a while so
i'm just glad she's like getting her
piece and
i mean what is it how many days in jail
45 days like that's not enough because
if you feel it's like she's obviously
now
i imagine she feels very afraid of him
but but did they say what five years
restraint probation probation and a
protective order
um that lasts five years but protective
orders are kind of [ __ ] from what
i've heard
it's just a piece of paper that's not
stopping someone from showing up and
harassing you no we need to really like
figure out a way to make that better
and we need to protect hayden panettiere
at all costs she's really the talent of
a generation and i think she's a
precious gem of a woman
do you think she'll come back and like
once things kind of the dust settles
like
she's a very talented actress i really
hope so and she can sing her potatoes
off yes she can
so and she's just an icon do you ever
see raising helen
no what never it's such
a good movie it's like a really old kate
hudson movie
oh okay so the love interests are kate
hudson and john corbett aiden shaw from
sex in the city
dead dead and the kids are played by
abigail breslin
oh my god i think the sun is abigail
breslin's brother can you fact check
that
and hayden panettiere are the kids is
she like a teenager in it yes
felicity huffman is their mom okay
spoiler alert
you know i won't spoil it and joan
cusack
stop it's literally a star-studded
amazing rom-com maybe one of my
favorites i talk about it all the time
raising helen raising helen i'll watch
it you and taylor
will love it it's like sad it's amazing
so there's lesbians in it
no is there no there's no lesbians you
guys will love it because it's a
beautiful story
the second i heard joan cusack and
lizzie hoffman
but i was like they're a couple taylor
you know i think of you as so much more
than a lesbian oh my god thank you so
much no you shaped that you will love
this movie okay
i can't believe you haven't seen it is
that a thing people have seen is it her
brother or no
yeah they look a lot alike okay it's
such a good move you've seen it have you
seen yeah everyone's seen it
is it because i'm a thousand years old
no because it's actually like an older
maybe not everyone's unit okay well just
watch it okay i think it's on netflix
okay
um okay next up a little tech news
because apple unveiled like all their
new products yesterday
oh so much [ __ ] we don't need okay
everything apple just announced new ipad
pros colorful imacs air tags and more
so they updated their ipad pro with a
chip from a desktop computer nobody
cares
they also announced a new line of imacs
like the desktop yeah they come in
different colors which i actually think
is kind of cool yeah
it's like a throwback to it's very retro
yeah i like that
yeah i mean it's like what other [ __ ] do
we need they're going to sell to us
right they are updating their apple tv
4k box with a new processor nobody cares
oh
with probably a new cord yeah oh yeah
don't eat ford don't even new corner i
want my dingle dangle jack
i don't want this one it's so [ __ ]
annoying so rude
but people are really excited about this
next one they're announcing um long
expected
lost item trackers called air tags so
they're basically like little tracking
devices you put on like wallets purses
so yeah and they have gps locations so
if you lose
your wallet i'm sticking it on my kid
one day yeah right exactly like i'm
i'm sticking it on like the backs of my
earrings because that's the [ __ ] i
actually lose
so they're 29 per tag or you can get
four for a hundred dollars that's
actually awesome there are tags like
this though
yes a lot of other companies like
apple's kind of late they're like
hella late but it's apple yeah and i saw
it on
i saw a company like that on shark tank
and they're doing quite well yeah i
forget what it's called
it's called like tracker [ __ ] you know
they also have a new iphone 12 color
purple nope
this is like not interested no it's just
like
this announcement wasn't that great
there's just like lots of different
colors do you think they feel like this
insane pressure to like always
have these big announcements quarterly
like [ __ ] they really set themselves
up for disappointment
this one's interesting they're launching
a podcast subscription service
um so they're putting themselves against
spotify and other competitors in the
audio streaming wars okay
but what does that mean a podcast
subscription service
podcasts are free i had a friend that
was given a job offer at apple
radio and it was a lot of money yeah
and like she didn't end up going because
she was in a contract with another
company i can't
name the name but she did say like she
was nervous
because she's like well what is apple
rape like who listens
they have so much money and they pay so
many celebrities to have radio shows
like kendall jenner has one luck one
i don't know anyone who's ever popped in
their headphones it was like i'm gonna
listen to apple radio i didn't really
know it was a thing
who the [ __ ] listens to that do you
think that apple is like gonna not have
a tee day
at some point in time ever in our
lifetime i mean apple is like so
integrated in our everyday lives like
it's wild i don't know how people who
don't have iphones like
have like survive like you don't have
face time if you don't have an iphone
you never go to starbucks i never go to
starbucks
i know so you're like primed to get an
android no i know actually i've heard
they're much better than that
um apple card is now expanding to kids
who are 13 years old like that's [ __ ]
weird um that's so weird that's pretty
much
it like this really wasn't that big of
an extravaganza
the big thing everyone's talking about
are the apple tags
yeah i mean i love a tag i lose
everything
i lose everything too but like that's
part of life it's fun and like okay so
somebody steals my wallet
yes they're throwing the tag in the
trash a million percent
but if you stick your wallet in the
freezer like i do
what because why wouldn't you put your
wallet in the freezer of course
it's like then it's very helpful yeah no
by the way like this literally happens
all the time
my friend i remember i was at a club
with my friend remember clubs my friend
alicia and her wallet
got stolen and it was like a wallet
purse so her phone was in there [ __ ]
we were able to track the phone and it
was literally on the corner of the club
so we run out we're calling the phone
you look in the trash literally her
wallet has been emptied but they throw
the phone in the wallet
in the in the trash oh my god so it's
like
i don't even know if a tracker would
help unless there's no way to get the
tracker off
well i mean also if it's like new to the
market people won't necessarily even
know
to look for them that's true and unless
it looks pretty big but if it's like
really
indiscreet stick it in the fold yeah i
love sticking things
in a crevice in a little crease um
i'm underwhelmed by the market you know
the apple market
same i've been though i feel like i just
like want to believe in myself and give
up an apple
you can't no okay maybe
like if for no other reason than like
the social implications of not being an
apple user now you're a weirdo if you
don't have
that no it's true and i'm sorry that
that offends people who don't have
androids but there is this stigma
i will say though that was also my
jealousy speaking my brother-in-law
refuses to use apple products i respect
that
and i really respect him i am such a
loser like i conform to all of society's
standards
because i have crippling self-doubt and
anxiety and i just want to be i just
want to fit in i try to be like
i do so like if i was secure enough in
myself to like never conform and just
like not have an android actually have a
lot of respect for people because i
could never be that
risky they're independent thinkers they
sound like they're the kind of people
that like themselves
oh can't relate
it is the fifth and final story brought
to you by blueprint test prep
you're never quite sure if the way
you're studying is going to drive
results we've always used index cards
and just read them over and over
it's hard to commit to studying and
getting a routine because of all the
distractions i.e
our iphones hello um i was never a very
good studier i would bury my head in a
textbook for hours but it felt like i
never improved on test scores
that's why you've got to try blueprint
blueprints test prep delivers
life-changing score increases
on average their students receive 11
point increases on the lsat
for future lawyers and 13 point
increases on mcad for future doctors
that is a very big deal yes they make
the boring interesting a shocking thing
they've learned over the years is that
when you're actually bored you don't
retain information very well
blueprint was founded on the idea that
test prep can be entertaining
and effective they use unique animations
and memorable graphics plus
humorous pop culture references to make
your experience engaging and enjoyable
like that's so true mnemonic devices are
always more helpful like if you're just
mindlessly reading like none of that
information is going to stay in your
brain
no they also have the only dynamic study
plan tool that creates your personalized
study plan at the click of a button
your plan will outline exactly what to
study evolve with your busy schedule and
sync to your phone so you stay on track
plus they only hire the best instructors
and tutors to teach for blueprint you
must score in the 90th percentile or
higher on an exam
they turn down over 90 of people who
apply to teach for them so you know
you're only getting the best of the best
instructors
if you're not taking any of these tests
like the mcat or lsat make sure to let
your friends and family know about
blueprint it'll change their life for
the better
blueprint's an incredible cup they've
got incredible contests going on right
now to win twenty thousand dollars
towards your law school tuition just
head to their site and enter to win
plus blueprint has an exclusive offer
for the morning toast listeners they
rarely offer discounts this is a bit
this is big
but for the first 100 listeners from our
show who go to blueprintprep.com and use
the promo code toast
you'll save 20 off so that's over 200
off your lsat or mcat class i know we
have a lot of toasters in grad school
so listen up again the first 100 people
who go to blue print
prep dot com and use the code toast can
save 200
um that's blueprintprep.com the promo
code is toast and they're running a
contest right now
to win 20 000 towards your law school
tuition so blueprintprep.com
um i took the lsat what yeah and i
[ __ ] sucked that's because you didn't
have blueprint no kidding i'm sitting
here being like
only i was around when that was
happening i am learning so much about
you
elsa yeah so my i'm from a family i mean
we're new englanders we're
education snobs and stuff yeah so when i
went to ithaca they were like
but my dad went to harvard and he's a
doctor in case i forgot to mention
it wow and so i was like i felt the
pressure to be a professional i was like
i'm not going to be a doctor because
like i can't i can't and i shan't
yeah but i could be a lawyer because i
like to talk and i also love legally
blonde
yeah so i took those good qualifications
thank you what'd you get
179. 179 i definitely did not i would
probably got
honestly i can't remember i blocked it i
think i got like a 114.
whatever the lowest score is i got that
i was so
painfully bad at law so and so did you
not decide to go to law school because
your scores were bad yeah and i was like
i'm not going to go to some crap school
because it's expensive yeah so i was
like i'm just going to go into the
workforce i'll go
be a radio host yeah you know i was like
i'm just going to go work and then i'll
retake the lsat and i'll like you know
i'll just like like what's the word uh
defer push it off yeah
self-defer and you never did that and
then i got into radio and i was like why
would i go to law school when i could be
a regular show host do you still have
like piles of like l-set books like
somewhere in your house
no i burned them and i danced naked
around the fire i'm dying okay fifth and
final story a little more
streaming news netflix
[Laughter]
netflix predicts that's hard to say it
is
their worst quarter for streaming growth
in its history why
this stock has fallen nine percent they
only added four million new subscribers
in the first quarter of this year
which is i know i'm so sad for you only
four million times 11
which is 44 million dollars i'm crying
for you
it's 2 million less than it expected and
it forecasts just a million editions in
the current quarter which would be the
lowest total yet
so netflix has come back down to earth
after static stratospheric gains during
the opening months of the cobia 19
pandemic
the streaming giant on tuesday reported
3.98 million new paid subscribers
in the first quarter which is down from
8.5 million reported in the previous
quarter
and then before that was six million um
and they predicted three months ago that
they would have six million for this
year but
they did not well the thing is they set
the bar so damn high
that it's like where do they have to go
it's either they stay stagnant or they
go down so i feel like
this type of like self-statistic is
difficult like they should be competing
against the rest of the industry
and i'm not gonna lie like i don't
really care what this means for the
streaming wars but here's what it means
for me
people are watching less netflix like
we're we're
we're almost out of the pandemic like
that's what this means to me like yes
when we were reporting on like 16
million people signed up for
uh netflix in the first three months of
covet i'm like oh [ __ ] we are like
doomed like we're all just gonna be in
our house getting fat like watching tv
yes and now it's like oh wait we are
leaving our houses we're not watching as
much tv like right we're going to
mykonos you know
that's what this story means to me i
agree and also
yeah i mean it's hard to cry for them
when they've still got 44 million
dollars
no i know it's like don't cry for me but
do you think it is also like the disney
plus the paramount plus and like
the competition the hbo i mean hbo has
like sick shows right now what do you
subscribe to like what do you pay for
okay
hulu amazon prime but i really like want
to stop supporting jeff bezos so i think
i'm gonna stop
how do you stop having amazon prime i do
not know but i'm how are you gonna
like order like cups like how are you
going to
open my door no and walk outside
and go to the drugstore
i know i'm serious like amazon prime if
i had to cancel anything i would never
cancel amazon prime because you get
prime video with your prime subscription
right
right but that's what i'm saying is we
have that but i might try to cut the
core because i'm going to try to
i'm going to try to like not make jeff
bezos more of a billionaire i think
that's a huge mistake because you know
what he's going to be a billionaire
regardless and you're going to be the
[ __ ] who's run out of cups
you know what this week taste of taylor
is all about taking down pesos
don't even listen to it no the thing is
like it's a lie
i get i get like the the message there
but there are crazy things though that
like
like in the pockets that we talk about
like that he does that you're like
what am i supporting of course but
but you're gonna make no impact on him
and it's just gonna like lessen the
quality of your life because amazon
as much as people like hate it it is the
most efficient way of getting groceries
these days
of getting literally anything you need
yeah so why would you just ruin your
life to make a point that's literally
going to do nothing what did you say
this weekend
what did i say oh i actually was
thinking about it by artificial by
international we were
we were driving home from the grocery
store and there was like this really
kind of like
you know like hippie jeep in front of us
that had like all these different
bumper stickers and one of them like
really spoke to me because it was
literally the antithesis of everything i
believe in it said
buy local no no buy organic buy local
and i'm like literally no if i had a
bumper sticker it would say
buy artificial buy internationally like
if it's not processed and made in china
like
i don't want it so that's my mantra
right now and that's why i love amazon
i respect that you want to have
principles i really do yeah but at the
expense of your own
like convenience yeah i don't know if i
agree with that
we're gonna see but uh so but for right
now
hulu prime netflix disney plus
because of my fiance's a child i love
disney plus by the way i never watch it
do you guys pay for it like as a
household or like you share with your
families
we pretty much our family share with us
we pretty much pay for all of them
hbo max and then i'm gonna get paramount
plus because
i'm on paramount plus oh yeah you
getting younger taylor hosts the after
show for younger which is literally my
favorite show new season is coming soon
it's out they it is so they dropped it
on paramount plus oh wait all the
episodes
uh for the first four the final season
and then i think it's gonna air on tv
land like in its regular season
but like with commercials in the whole
shebang if you want it early you have to
get paramount plus
oh my god i did not know that first of
all i will be getting powerman plus
second of all
taylor knows the ending she won't tell
me i don't even wanna know i won't i
won't
i don't want to know i i would never
ruin that moment that i got to have with
the end of the show because it's
basically
it's like a sex in the city it's like
carry you know petrovsky big like it's
okay i'm excited for it you are on
powerman plus that's so exciting you're
on a streaming service i know so getting
younger the after show is also on it so
i'm definitely gonna get that and i'm
trying to think what else i kind of want
to get showtime just because there are
shows that i love there but i don't know
but you know i know you want to get rid
of amazon but you know you can subscribe
to showtime through amazon
and pay seven dollars oh fine i guess i
give up
i'm just saying it's so convenient but
yes i have like every streaming service
too
but i only like i pay for hbo max and
chair with the family like olivia pays
for disney and shares it with the family
smart we all just kind of hold our own
jackie
um had a discovery plus and refused to
give anyone her passport which was
really [ __ ] up because like
we have a system wait why what was her
logic behind that
she like i called her she was raving
about discovery plus on the podcast oh
also i have an update from you guys for
you guys about jackie i totally forgot
i'll get that in a second
she was raving raving raving about how
the cooking shows have been so like
therapeutic and it's just like a great
thing to watch
so i call her and i'm like okay download
a discovery plus like give me your
password she's like honestly i don't
know i like just make your own i'm like
excuse
me i'm like we have a system here we all
share everything which is the way it
goes
girlfriend five profiles on netflix
profiles on hbo max i'm like what the
[ __ ]
she wouldn't give it to me so i signed
up for a free trial and then i cancelled
it she was so rude i'm dead
but i did want to update everyone on
jackie's uh progress before we dive into
deer toasters which is our advice
segment yes so i don't know if you know
jackie's on this kind of wellness
retreat
i wasn't sure if she was on vacation or
what well did
define vacation because she's on this
like health retreat no no no that's not
a vacation vacation is eating everything
in sight yep and drinking like a fish
yes
so i spoke to her this morning because i
have been getting a lot of messages
people wanting an update from her she's
really kind of off the grid she's just
not posting part of the world
immediately
right it's just like finding your inner
your inner peace
um but she's doing really well she
wasn't sure about which facility to go
to and
the one that she wanted to go to was so
expensive i literally would not let her
pay that
so she found a much more reasonably
priced one um but you know you do get
what you pay for so we were afraid she
was going to show up
and um be shot you know but she was not
it's
lovely she's she said she's found
everything she was looking for
good she was just looking for like a
like a calm retreat
to you know balance her health her mind
to work out
and she's so happy there she thanks
everyone for reaching out she's just
like
taking time away and she said she's
doing really good i mean she literally
facetimes me every day so she's like
still on her phone
but um she's doing really well so good
that was an update for everyone
and now we're gonna dive into your
toasters oh my god i'm out of breath
give me a second i just spit all over
myself
[Laughter]
okay diving into your toasters which is
brought to you by better help
is there something interfering with your
happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals i don't know say
str uh anxiety better help will assist
your
will assess your needs and match you
with your own licensed professional
therapist
where you can start communicating in
under 48 hours better help is not a
crisis line and it is not self-help it
is professional counseling and it's done
securely online
there's a broad range of expertise
available and they may not locally be
available to you
so it's great for stuff for it's a great
service for clients worldwide
basically you log into your account
anytime and you can send a message to
your counselor
where you'll get timely and thoughtful
responses plus you can schedule a weekly
video or phone session so you won't ever
have to go and sit in an uncomfortable
waiting room as you do with traditional
therapy
betterhelp is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches so they make
it easy and free to change
counselors if needed it's more
affordable than traditional offline
counseling and they offer financial aid
it is available
so go to betterhelp.com toast
that's better h-e-l-p join the over a
oh my god
visit betterhelp.com toast that's better
h-e-l-p
and join the over a million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional in fact so many people have
been using betterhelp that they are
recruiting additional counselors in all
50 states
this podcast is sponsored by betterhelp
and the morning toast listeners get 10
off their first month at betterhelp.com
toast
all right dear toasters our advice
segment if you ever want to write in
it's dear toasters at gmail.com
first up it's a little bit long okay i
like more ones first of all
hi love you guys and i need your help
a few weeks ago i went to look at
apartments because i'm moving to my
first place without a roommate
when i arrived for my first showing the
realtor was no joke the most beautiful
man i've ever
laid eyes on he was so cool and i felt
like we really hit it off
once i signed for the place i was no
longer at risk of seeing this man ever
again i decided to shoot my shot and ask
him for drinks
he said yes i was shook both that he
said yes and that i found a man in the
wild
since then i've gone on a few great
dates and i had some solid makeout
sessions
when i'm with him he seems so cool very
normal and we have great conversations
honestly potential boyfriend material we
both discussed that we were
what we were looking for and seem to be
on the same page the issue is that when
i'm not with him he is
the worst only replies to my messages
with repulsive attempts at flirting and
being cute and they are so cringy
they make me want to die i can't even
ask him how his days going without him
turning it around into some sort of
attempted flattery
of course it's nice sometimes but every
message he calls me weird nicknames
constantly tells me that he misses me
even though we've only hung out a few
times
and other things that make him seem like
a total schmooze when i
see his name pop up on my phone it gives
me a pit in my stomach
my question is what do i do this man
seems so normal in real life but the way
he acts when i'm not with him is painful
he is a stage f is he a stage five
clinger or just a bad flirt
how do i politely tell him to chill the
[ __ ] out sincerely a toaster who just
wants a normal man
i hate this because i know i i get it
like yeah oh my god like
texting it's so it sucks because it's
such an important part of like
relationships but it really shouldn't be
it really shouldn't be because it's just
like about the connection but this is a
problem we live in a 20 she's a 21st
century gal
i know god well the thing is i i dated
this guy one time and he was like so
good on paper
and he like said he would buy me
chanel's which is like really the way to
my heart so i
wanted to be with him but he in person
was cringy he gave me a pit and one time
he
like did the biggest like spit string in
my life and i like wanted
so i know the feeling yeah but it's i
i'm trying to
like figure out is it different in
person than it is on the phone because
like
the thing that hooked me to my fiance
now and made me a lesbian
was her texting skills oh wow it is
important but you're right like it could
be so much worse like
would you rather have someone who's
terrible in person but a great texter
or someone who's green person and just
text weird some people just grew up and
didn't learn the proper social
boundaries when it comes to texting
maybe just like
stop texting him so much i actually feel
like great relationships like
really flourish when you text so much
then you mean person you literally have
nothing to talk about i agree with that
call him i know that sounds scary like
an attack time
voice memo oh yes
solved yeah i would just be trying to
wean off the text messaging which is
hard for people our age
i know that's such an integral part of
like connections well in all voicemails
are for grandmas and moms and i get like
cold calling people feels like an
assassination so how about just do the
voice memos because maybe then he'll
learn through example to do them back
but what about face time
we aren't we aren't compatible why that
is like
what a terrorist you are if you face i
know oh my god
but i actually feel like people have
really cute like face time like
conversations
no they do i mean taste family
constantly facetimes
and i love so much i'm like why are you
why do you have to look at me right now
i know but it's like once you're
comfortable with someone it can actually
be like a really great way of
communicating yeah me and my 15 chins
have a blast facetime
um but that's why you could also like
you know work it with angles and
lighting it's but that is exhausting
dating is exhausting so get on board
taylor
i say try a new method of communication
when you're not in person and give this
guy a chance because i feel like if
it's not worth breaking up with someone
no no no no it's such a great story like
he told me my apartment like it's so
cute
and he's cute yeah and he's obviously
successful like he's a real job
how rare that is seriously sounds like
there's more good than bad here i
wouldn't let it bother you that much
try all right next up hey claudia and
jackie
taylor i have a weird one for you i'm 27
and currently live in los angeles i
don't consider myself someone who's so
la
but i don't know if i can claim that
after this back in 2018 i casually dated
this guy in the film industry
let's say his name is andrew we dated
for eight months super casual friends
with benefits
he works on a bunch of tv shows and
movies but it was his dream to be a
director
that christmas he flew home to new york
and while he was there he reconnected
with his college girlfriend
and it nearly turned his whole world
upside down he came back to l.a and told
me all about it
this kid looked borderline shell-shocked
because his reconnection had made him
nearly uproot his whole life and moved
back to new york to be with her
but he never did it and six months later
we stopped hooking up because it was
amicable
but it was amicable right flash forward
to now we've long parted ways and date
other people and i see on social media
that he's finished filming his first
indie movie so obviously i'm curious
what it's about
i just about lose my mind when i see the
storyline it's identical
to what happened over the holidays
i just about lose my mind when i see the
storyline is identical to what happened
over the holidays while we were dating
and the three main characters
are him the ex-girlfriend he couldn't
move on from and the new girl in his
life
aka me oh my god she's got the same hair
the same eyes and based on some set
photos
nearly the same outfits i wore on some
of our dates
i should also mention he texted me out
of the blue last year letting me know he
got funding for a film
and asked if i would consider him using
my apartment living room for a few
scenes
since they needed a feminine space i
said no because of cobid but now i'm
wondering if this was supposed to be the
living room for the character
version of me the movie comes out
sometime this year but what do i do with
this information
do i just message him being like am i a
character in your movie or do i just
wait for this premiere and hope to god
i'm portrayed well
sincerely a very la toaster wow
i have to say something it's a crazy
story but it's an indie film so like
don't worry no one cares like it's not
it's not legit unless you care about
like this guy and like you
maybe like could see a relationship with
him in the future this could just be
like a fab like a story about like who
you are now like one of your crazy
stories like i don't think you have to
like figure it out as somebody who lives
my life to tell
my story which then involves other
people's story i'd be a hypocrite
to like say this guy's in the wrong but
what i really don't like is that he
asked to use her apartment without
giving her
intel it would have just been nice to
get a heads up period especially since
he asked you
like that's my thing like if you just
like saw it on social and he didn't ask
it's like well it's his like
his version his story his right yeah but
the fact that he did involve you for
your apartment then he should have like
ponied up the information
yeah but i don't know if you don't
really care about this guy anymore i
don't really feel like you need to like
hash it out like this could just be like
a funny story you tell when you're drunk
yes and you could always use more of
those stories i know i can
yeah what's your go-to drunk story my
go-to drunk story
probably the fact that i reset my
engagement ring from my ex-husband
that's a good one that's also your go-to
sober story
well i'm always drunk really that's no
different our third and final dear
trusters is an update okay from a
previous one
hi guys i previously emailed about my
friend who really smelled
she smelled her clothes smelled her car
smelled it was bad i'm happy to
i'm happy to report that in the past
year she did a complete 180 and made her
health and hygiene a priority
and she no longer smells or wears
clothes that smell
unfortunately there's a new problem
i recently started dating someone and a
few nights ago i told my ex smelly
friend
that my new guy sent me a sexual text he
sent it to he sent it when i was with
her and i was caught off guard because
we haven't even had sex yet so i
mentioned it to her
she said that if her boyfriend had
texted that to her she'd break up with
him
this is where the problem comes in i
started fuming and she recently got back
with her loser ex
and maybe she has pretend amnesia but i
have text messages from her where she
unfortunately shared that he went to
orgies
and got tied up and got his butt licked
by people
this smelly butt i'm sorry i i just i
need to start from the beginning
i have text messages from her where she
shared that he went to orgies got tied
up and had his butt licked by other
people
i swear to god she told me that he ties
a belt around his neck when he
masturbates so he can pass out
to each of their own but i could have
gone my entire life without knowing that
and hello isn't that dangerous
should i remind her of these things that
she told me about her then
ex and what he did when they were broken
up and she hated him i don't get why she
would react
that way to a text message that was
nothing compared to what she would judge
her boyfriend for when they weren't
together
please help i mean that there's a lot
that took a turn
we went from smelly to asphyxiation now
uh this friend okay so basically the
quandary here
is that like her friend is being really
judgmental about this guy she's seeing
sending her sex but he's like
we know what your ex-boyfriend did and
you were totally fine with it so it's
like now judgey wedgie was a bear when
your boyfriend was getting his butt
licked well here's the thing so stinky
mcgee's mad at you for telling her that
she was stinking
so she hates your breath oh that's it
so she is she is just sitting here like
waiting for you to give her any
information either your life or your
boyfriend
that she can judge and make you feel as
bad as you made her feel but the thing
is
you're being good friends i didn't even
think of that you need to tell your
friend that you smell
you need to tell your friend that you
smell but i do remember saying that like
sometimes people smell
not because they're dirty but because
it's like some sort of um like halitosis
or some [ __ ] like that yeah it's like a
do i smell no no but not like a disease
it's like a they're rotting from inside
out
no some people have like disorders that
make them smell i actually know someone
who does so like
really not like not like from the mouth
not in the body yes
so there are like side effects of
different medications like it's all it
could be all these different things so
you have to be really sensitive when you
tell someone they smell because oh yeah
it's true if it's hygienic
i think most of the time it's not
hygienic because most people will know
when they smell like a normal person who
like has a working nose not if they had
coven they can't smell and taste anymore
i am like every day i'm like do i smell
do a smell do it smell you don't smell
you look great i swear
yeah but i just think you have to be
sensitive in how you you do you
just be like you stink i remember stinky
mcgee husband
like my mom would come and stay with us
in our mansion apartment and
one time he was like your mom's perfume
my mom wears chantilly from walgreens
it's like such a thing
and my mom is so [ __ ] fabulous like
it's the one thing it's like my dad when
he was poor medical school bought a fern
so it's like their youth
their youthful romance even though it's
like cheap cheap drugstore
[ __ ] it's just like their thing yeah so
he was and she douses in it and so
he was like you have to sell your mom
she's not allowed to spray her perfume
in the apartment and i was like you can
tell my mom like i'm not gonna
and that was something that doesn't even
smell bad so i get how hard it can be
yes
to tell somebody they stink so like the
fact that you did that is
it really is brave good brave friend
thing to do but she she's mad hates you
she's mad yeah like that's what it is
yeah we all know that that's a good
point i totally didn't even think of
that yeah
but honestly this girl sounds like
trouble like is a friendship worth
pursuing
first she smells and then she's
judgmental like it's honestly like i
don't think it's worth the trouble
i don't either i mean there are plenty
of fishes in the scene
especially when it comes to friendship
yeah like not every
friendship is meant to last forever no
but we're sorry you're dealing with that
but thank you for being vulnerable and
opening up to us and giving us an update
if we have read your prompt on aaron you
want to update us
you can email us deartoasters gmail.com
or if you just are having some trouble
and you need some thoughtful advice from
two fabulous gals dear toasters
gmail.com
taylor schrecker thank you a million
times for being here if you guys liked
what you heard
taylor strucker has a two-hour radio
show every single day on patreon and
it's patreon.com
the taylor striker show yes you could
also just follow her on instagram
taylor's tracker for all the information
on your show
yep i love you i love you thank you i'm
honored guys this is our last show of
the week i am headed to
florida for some sun i'm jealous
i really thank you all for putting up
with me this week sorry about monday
sorry about tuesday sorry about
wednesday
hope you guys have an amazing week thank
you so much for listening to the morning
shows millennial morning show where we
deliver the fast five stories that you
need to know every monday through friday
on youtube so
if you're watching us on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast and
where podcasts can be found so it's
spotify itunes stitcher public radio i
heart ready to catch box all the places
so wherever you listen to podcasts find
us a morning totally the five star
review about how beautiful stunning and
smart we are
have an amazing hump day hump someone
you love i'll be humping taylor
love you taylor thank you so much bye
guys